- [Instructor] One cannot
compare the running speed
of the cheetah with other mammals.
They underlined other mammals.
So let's think about what's going on here.
They say, one cannot compare.
Now what are the things
that they're saying
one cannot compare?
So they're saying the
running speed of the cheetah,
that's one of the things they're saying
that you cannot compare,
and then they're saying
you cannot compare it with other mammals.
So is this a reasonable
comparison right over here,
comparing the running speed of something
with other mammals?
Well, you're comparing a speed
with animals right over here.
That doesn't make sense.
Now it might be hard to spot,
because you might say okay,
would I compare the cheetah
with other mammals, and
that would make sense
if the sentence was one cannot compare,
if it just said the
cheetah with other mammals,
then this would make sense.
You're comparing one
mammal to other mammals.
So that would have been
a reasonable comparison.
But that's not what's going on here.
We're saying the running
speed of the cheetah
with other mammals.
So really what the author,
the person writing it,
is saying one cannot
compare the running speed
of the cheetah with the running speed
of other mammals, or with
the speed of other mammals.
With, so I would insert there, the speed,
or the running speed, of other mammals.
You're comparing speed to speed.
Now which of these choices
have something like that?
So I definitely wanna, I
definitely wanna change things.
One cannot compare the running speed
of the cheetah with that of other mammals.
Yeah, I mean that seems reasonable.
Instead of saying the
speed, we can say that.
So one cannot compare the running speed
of the cheetah with that of,
with that of other mammals.
So that being the speed of other mammals.
So that, this one seems pretty good.
One cannot compare the running speed
with any other mammals.
Well, no, here you're still
comparing speed to mammals.
That's strange.
And then here, you're
still comparing speed
to all other mammals.
Cannot compare the running
speed with all other mammals,
so it doesn't make sense.
You're comparing a speed to animals,
so definitely like that one.